either challenge for us I think we've
got three big challenges as a
Progressive Party how do we deliver
progressive values in a fiscally cold
climate when government doesn't have so
much money how do we continue to build
the fairer more equal society we want to
see when technology is disrupting so
much of what we do that's creating lots
of opportunities but it's destroying
jobs that people in many parts of the
country have been doing for generations
and how do we pay our way in the world
now if we're to tack all these new
challenges the tasks that we have in
some senses is is that that john
prescott used to talk about is how do
you apply our traditional progressive
values in this different setting and I
don't think replaying the old tunes of
the past is the way what we want to do
is take what we did in the past that
were successful forward and come up with
new solutions for the new challenges I
just set out that we face looking
forward in the future
so no more Blair right no more Brown
nights where one Labor Party and I you
know I'm looking forward to this contest
because I think it's a great time for us
to actually have a debate about how we
win in 2020 and make no mistake about it
we've got a big challenge we are going
to need to win back I think at least 90
seats when they're going to need to make
at least 90 games we've of course got to
do better in Scotland if we want to win
again I'm absolutely confident that we
can do that I don't buy this notion that
somehow this is the beginning of a
ten-year project we've got to do this in
five years we owe it to the communities
who have already been hit very hard by
the last Tory led coalition and we know
we'll be hit even harder by this David
Cameron led pure Tory government